jump in here
all right hop breath averse thank you
for your patience there
we are back with another hot breath the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
our guest today
out of over 300 comics we have
interviewed on here
this is the comic that inspired me to
start my comedy career and he doesn't
like being called
a comedian he likes being called a
storyteller that has humor with a punch
we'll get into that but the first time i
saw his album
20 stories tall and then his special 10
stories tall and just
his unique point of view regardless of
what he is you call him a singer a comic
just an overall man of god
he is one of the funniest minds on the
planet and we're so thrilled to have him
here in the hot breath the verse let's
welcome the one and only mark lowry
everyone let's show him some love hello
joel
so good to be with you on your show we
if they knew
how much trouble we had because i just
went live
recently and you got on there and said
hey mark i'm going to talk to you in a
few minutes
and i said can we go let's start a
little early and you said yes
because my i have physical therapy at
two o'clock
yes come on in everybody have a seat i'm
talking to joel
buyer he's a comedian and he tells me
that my stuff inspired him and i'm
honored so we're all
i'm i'm live with you guys he's live
with his people
and then he's also recording this for a
you do a video podcast i have a youtube
channel hot breath comedy network and a
podcast called hot breath
okay yeah you can get that if you want
to
yeah yeah uh so let's go what do you
want to ask me
[Laughter]
so tell me how important i am so we'll
um i know we started early
we ended up starting right when we
planned to which is hilarious
so um yeah we'll uh we'll keep this
rather tight but i would be interested
to ask first off what is it i've and
researching you you don't like to be
called a comedian and you're very
intentional about
not being labeled a comic why is that
well it's because i'm scared
i'm serious when you say here comes a
comedian
uh you better be funny mm-hmm you know
and i
honestly got my start with no intention
of ever being funny
i was trying to do something between the
songs
because the lord called me at college i
mean i'm a christian
and therefore been labeled a christian
comedian
but i never gave myself that title i
think i'm a storyteller because what i
did i
went to these little churches and i
would sing a song and tell a story
sing a song tell a story and i thought
the songs
were the most important thing but what i
come to find out
what people really enjoy the most and
what i
actually enjoy the most probably is
talking and hearing people laugh
and i come from a you know funny family
my brother's a lot funnier than me
at least that's what he tells me and
and my dad he's a funny guy and his
brothers oh my gosh you would go to
lowry family reunion and
everybody has two gifts they can all
talk and listen at the same time
because there's ten conversations going
all over that room and everybody's tuned
into every conversation
and then we're making comments into
those conversations and
it's a great life for the attention
deficit disordered
person that i am but that's what
resonated i think with your comedy
is and i think you first realized you
were funny when you made your brother's
friends
laugh i believe if that's correct and
well they weren't really his friends my
brother did
some modeling in houston that's where
you get it from
yeah well he was good looking no no no
no i had to be funny or i would not have
been noticed
funny and a mullet let's not forget
that's all i had
i grew into that years later no when i
was a kid we had burr
haircuts you know what a fur is a bird
it's just shaved right to the scalp my
dad gave us one every summer and i
loved it i would still wear it like that
except i look like uncle fester
from the adams
[Laughter]
so you you you're scared to be called a
comic even though you're
proven to be funny well i
understand people have to label you
something
and that's not the worst thing but i
just think if you say okay ladies and
gentlemen now welcome the funniest
guy and he's so
funny well you better be funny
that's true and i would rather let them
say y'all this guy is gonna
bore you into oblivion and then i make
because see let me tell you when i
started out in those independent
fundamental baptist churches
that wouldn't clap because that's giving
glory to men
yeah i see your face they wouldn't shout
because they're afraid someone might
think they're doing it in another
language
but they would laugh and i knew they
were listening
and all i cared about is are these
people listening
because you couldn't tell by looking at
them you know
bad independent baptist and back in my
day they were dead or in the door now
now they love jesus and they memorize
those scriptures
but they're don't want they do not want
to be thought of as charismatic
and so they wouldn't they wouldn't
that's giving glory to men if you
applaud you they'd say amen
at the end of a song or something but
they wouldn't you know i don't know it's
all changed now and it's gotten better
have you ever done comedy clubs or
anything oh lord no
oh so you've oh not not even tried not
even curious i tried one time that was
enough
out of my mind well my dad went with me
it was a
guy that i'd met who owned a comedy club
in atlanta when i lived in acworth
oh snap yeah i lived in acworth
for a while when i joined the vocal band
i was living in acworth georgia
wow yeah so
uh there's i met a guy who owned a
comedy club and he had seen me and he
thought
i could do it he said you got all these
faces and you got the
you know you can do this and he talked
me into it
and uh i never did it again but what
happened
let's get into this well i think they
laughed
but it wasn't the kind of laughter i was
used to i don't know what was different
about it
you know first of all my crowd is
usually sober
yes you know and i'm not i'm not
accounting for all of them but most of
them
and hey i'm kidding about that i mean
and and and i know where they're coming
from i know how they think
i'm one of them i was raised with them
i don't want to leave them i don't want
to go
do i did the interview for people
magazine they said you want to cross
over
and i said yes if i can take the
crossover
but i don't want to go without him
uh-huh
and i just i have no desire to do that
i've never had
it's not my calling and i thank god for
people like you
and others jeff foxworthy loves the lord
and he is
hauling the water to the desert well i'm
fine with singing for the choir
see have you ever bombed on stage then
do you ever have an experience like that
yeah with bill one time i was you know
with bill gaither
what was so glorious about the humor
that we
created really because when i joined him
i had never done anything but monologues
i'd never had another person on stage
with me so i would do a monologue and he
would interrupt me
from the piano bench and then i'd turn
around and sass him and that led to this
and that the other
and after a few nights of me sassing him
we got rid of the monologues that i was
doing
that that just stayed in my solo shows
and he and i created this
he's the old man and i was the perpetual
10 year old
you know jumping around making fun of
his hair they always kept my mic
on because you could not if my mic
wasn't hot
the joke was over by the time they
turned it up you know that
timing i mean so bob
bill bob bob told them to keep my mic
hot
so they did and which i loved of course
and some things worked some
didn't one night something i said didn't
work that popped in my head and it was
crickets
and bill said well that one
that didn't go yeah on stage he's you
know he said well i said well i'll just
save that for when i go secular
right oh my gosh
the audience didn't care because they
knew you know
i had no ever i mean if they knew me
they know i don't care about going
second
we had 20 000 people the night i said
that on stage
very few secular shows have 20 000
people you know that's what that's when
gaither was at the
height of the vocal band i mean we were
soaring
howard and vestal were alive that big
homecoming tour was on the road it was
huge
and bill caught me at intermission and
said you're gonna go apologize to that
crowd
i said why he said because you said
that's for when you go
secular and i'm going is this man lost
his mind
surely he knows they know i'm kidding
i guess and i said i'm not doing it
he said oh oh yeah you i said i read
my lips i'm not apologizing
for saying that and so i then i thought
about it
and and then i got up there that
afterwards i want to let him
force me to do anything you know i'm not
going to apologize for anything i've
ever said unless
i feel like it you know that's a lie
if you're apologizing because someone
twisted your arm you're not sorry
but i thought it over and i got upset
listen y'all
bill chewed me out in intermission told
me i have to apologize to y'all because
i said that joke was for when i go
secular you know the one that bombed
and i said let me just tell you this we
have 20 000 people here tonight where am
i gonna go
if i want a bigger crowd where am i
gonna go seriously
and i'm not called to go secular
i thank god for those people who are you
know i'm not called
to be a plumber either but i thank god
for those people who are
you know i'm not called to be a doctor
but i thank god for dr michael grieser
who fixed my foot
i was gonna say you're not called to
ride any scooters again as well
ever we learned that after breaking your
leg twice doing that
oh yeah yeah i broke my broke my leg
twice on that same road yeah this has
gotten too serious hadn't this supposed
to be funny no
this is this is like the the inside the
actor's studio for comedians we
we show like the stories behind the
comics so you're you're in good company
so
well how many you got live on your on
your i got 1500 how many you got why you
got to do me like that mark
oh because you're a puppy and you
deserve to have fewer numbers
we got 18 strong over here good i'm glad
you know what they matter i was going to
say they do but then when you
threw out your number like how many do
you have by the way i you know that you
know that we know that i have more
just so you know just so you don't think
i'm like
i do you're on i mean every day you have
hundreds of people on your live streams
but that's it's aspirational you've
raised you know what isn't it
fun too it is fun enjoy it yeah
it is 19 now not to brag 19
now especially during a pandemic i love
checking in on these people first of all
they now we got 1600 they wouldn't be
following me
if they didn't you know
like me checking in on them i like
checking in on them and see what you
don't understand
we don't do a lot of humor on the
check-in you watch it i sing we sing out
of these old hymnals that i got my
laptop jacked up on because we couldn't
connect them but i
know yeah when they when they have the
laptop like this you know on those shows
and
all you see is the most hideous part of
the human body
all of this right here singing out of
their chin yeah
oh you've got to get it above jeans
yeah i need to get better at singing i
want to incorporate that let me uh i
heard you
listen i heard you a little bit uh-huh
and i just let that go
what about joseph did you know
maybe a remix right it's kind of elvis
vibrato you got going there
oh so i can sing
tell my wife elvis vibrato you know i'm
working on joseph did you know
uh what did i say mary did you know
joseph did you know and
jesus we know you knew uh-huh you're
working are you are you being serious
i didn't know if you had a remix up your
sleeve maybe a hip-hop remix
no did you know there is a disco version
of mary did you know
i did not know mary didn't know that
either it's incredible
it's it's by a lady named christine w
and she enunciates every word
and it's a merry did you mary
i mean it's a disco and it played in
disco
bars all over the world one christmas
and i didn't have to leave the house and
i told everybody in those bars what i
think about jesus
now is that not cool that's powerful
yeah and i never had to leave the house
you never feel you you've got yeah
you're you're you're good you've got
residuals on residuals
you don't have to leave the house ever
if you don't want to well
i love it it's well deserved though oh
we're down to 1400 getting more
entertaining well we're up to 20 so not
to brag
we're up to 22 now so when people let me
ask you this since you're interviewing
me and i'm in
so if people want to come see you do
your comedy which i told you if you ever
get to houston you need to let me know
i will for sure but they can go to where
to find out more about you
my website is joelbuyerscomedy.com i
have a comedy special on there called
the trophy husband
and i have more info about my podcast
and when i'll be back on the road and
things like that
hey but i'm a 10 been doing comedy
almost 11 years now
and uh mark's the whole reason for the
season
unbelievable so can i put that where
they could see you i mean
how do you what was so cool in looking
back at your
your uh stand up or your storytelling to
prepare for this was like
your ability to incorporate physicality
into your
performance how do you how do you tell a
story
like verbally but then add that like
fourth dimension
of the characterization of it well can
you give me an example of what street i
don't know
you mean my face yeah like your facial
expressions are incredible well let me
tell you a story about that
it i vide metzger
of the kansas city youth for christ she
and her husband
she just passed away godly wonderful
lady
and they would they had a channel 50 was
the station in kansas city it was a
christian tv
it was the first time i was ever
videotaped from beginning to end of one
of my shows right
or the young people at the kansas city
youth for christ
which was probably 1981
somewhere back i graduated from college
in 80 and by 1981-8283 somewhere in
there
i was going to kansas city youth for
christ once a year well
they videotaped one of my performances
and let me tell you joel byers it was
the first time mark lowry
had ever seen his faces
now i used to make faces in the mirror
when i was a kid
just because we didn't have iphones yet
you know we were limited with what we
could do to entertain ourselves
and i would my belts are getting a
mirror
and make all these faces and i would die
laughing right yeah that's the one
yeah and then uh like that or that
can go either way wow so then
and my mother's very expressive her face
was you know she'd get mad her
eyebrows would shoot to the back of her
skull you know
and so i went with at first let me just
be honest with you
the night i i remember it like it was
yesterday i slayed
they had like a an office area to kansas
city
for christ and they had a tv on a on a
stand that was back in the days when tvs
were huge you know
you know not huge like they are now but
you know heavy
so sitting on a stand i was lying on the
laying lying i was prostrating across
straight on the floor
and i think i got that one right and
uh yeah and
um i saw my faces for the first time
ever
and i almost quit the i mean i've had so
many
quitting periods really into my life and
calling first of all the lord didn't
tell me he was going to turn into comedy
he called me to sing
[Music]
but i noticed you know like i said that
they look bored when i sang but boy
they'd sit on the edge of their seat
when i started telling my tales
yeah and i thought well man i better
dance with who brought me
so i think the lord was sneaky
he did not let me know if he just said
mark i want you to go into comedy i'd
have found myself in the belly of a
whale
if you know what i'm saying jonah and
the whale member
oh i'm listening to you he called the
prophet and the prophet ran
because well you know i mean oh lord if
he'd told me because that's scary to me
and if you're not a little bit scared
you're kind of simple
to get up and think you can make a room
full of people laugh yeah
don't aren't you a little nervous those
butterflies i mean it's a good
feeling now it's like oh that feels it's
like oh that gives me energy i'm ready
to go
for sure but in the early days it was
like oh my goodness what am i
what yep and then some days it's up
other days it's down
and you're like yeah i'm gonna be the
next big comic and then the next day
you're like
oh i'm quitting comedy and going back to
enterprise rent a car
i can't do this but the difference is
you wanted to be a comedian right
yes yeah always always and then i
decided to do it senior year of college
the first time i actually tried it but i
wanted to be a comedian my whole life
after hearing seriously 20 stories tall
and you bringing your real life
experiences
to the stage and being so vivid about it
and my mom my mom said that you um
you reminded her uh so much of me
and like our adhd and our experiences
with teachers
and uh we're about to we're gonna we're
gonna wrap this up here
in a minute here just so you can get to
your physical therapy but
i want to bring on a special guest
because
this is the person responsible for us
even being here
today oh really yes you must be your
mother yeah it is
let's give it up for mama joel in here
mama mama joel in here
hey hey mark
hi oh hold on i gotta get my screen
around i'm on the screen
there we go wait i don't see her oh
she's
uh she's on the zoom okay then i gotta
get up in the corner to see her okay go
ahead yeah
mama hey mark
hey mom look at us hey
we're doing it yeah thanks for joining
it's so nice to meet you you seem to
have a very nice son i do
i do yeah do you like his comedy
i do i do does he ever embarrass you
um sometimes well yeah he better
territory
well you know my mom she had a lot of
kids come up to her and say
are you really a screamer and she said
well that's the way
he heard it
[Laughter]
yeah they were there was a lot of
commonalities in your stories
and uh when joel's sisters heard the
stories on 20 stories tall
they they said that's joel that's joel
now i do have one question about your
mama
did she really witness to the obscene
phone callers
oh no it wasn't obvious yeah one yes she
would
yeah definitely but the madeline murray
o'hare one
oh my god it's the one i remember most
specifically oh yeah but she would
oh she lived for an obviously phone call
but we didn't get many
you know yeah once you tell them about
jesus they usually lose your number
but she's planting those seeds oh yeah
she witnessed that the kroger lady
she went i got my hair cut one time and
she
had that barber on his knees before we
left and
[Laughter]
oh that's all this is this is history
right here mark i've never brought my
mom on the show before but i had to for
you
i'm sorry i love that your mom
called you hyper creative
because i always thought a joel was
tigger and did not want to
temper that because he wasn't being
tigger all over the place on everybody's
nerves
he just wasn't you know he wasn't being
joel
but i loved your stories about miss
holland i'm a retired teacher
um and she just recently she just
recently passed away
oh my gosh joel had a teacher in the
third grade miss frida grier i've tried
to find her
she saw in joel what other teachers
didn't appreciate
so she he was great he did have some
really good teachers who did appreciate
appreciate his sense of humor and
imagination his hyper creativity
exactly exactly well i'm fixing to take
this
broken foot thank you mother thank you
for hanging out mike hey mama thank you
you're you're
young enough to be my daughter i can
tell so i just call you by
the first name linda god bless you yes
mark call me actually you're only about
two weeks older than i am
oh is that right well joel you can call
me mr lowry from now on
yes sir mr mr lowry thank you so much
for your time is there anything you want
to promote or anything
oh tonight shonda pierce and i are going
to be uh
together on her little uh show she she's
charging tickets
and this is the second time she's done
it it's me ken davis
and shonda and i don't know what we're
going to do but probably
won't be half as entertaining as this
was all right well thank you
mark lowry thanks for uh making me a
comedian
all right joel god bless you buddy god
bless you thank you
you